amparado no mesmo despacho am ea o
trabalho ainda não tem um dia eu
para ele os dias a falar concluiu
dizendo olha vou ter muitos ganhos
rp ian eu tenho que ficar nu na
tecnologia e na cozinha
eventualmente uma portaria não sabe o
que quer mesmo a reduzir manuel a
organização eu agradeço o convite por
esta esta fita e para tentar começar a
explicar que não é inclusive uma massa
tem uma fita estão tendo seu primeiro
cargo isto agora cortes tributários do
estado mais rapidamente que o metro
isso já tem 12 de maio continua a fazer
isso eu faço isso vai subindo cada vez
mais rapidamente no metro dividido em
três vezes mais outras duas vezes outras
duas vezes outras vezes eu fizer isto é
um milhão de vezes tem um mícron nunca
um micrômetro coisa que é bastante
rápida eu fizer isso agora
mil vezes mais tem um nome e aqui e aqui
minhas coisas começam a ficar realmente
interessante porque a velocidade com que
isso vai ao celular é muito rápida e eu
posso usar fiz realmente em aplicações
que agora que eu vou começar a mostrar e
evitar portanto não irá acompanhar as
fãs são muito técnicos não tem que ser
só tem a crescer
o que significam a já só que um carinho
sobre a sobre as várias funções que
serão enivaldo tecnologias por exemplo
estamos com o pacto da organização
utilizava por d'água
depois passou a ser uma jornada
um outra outra fase em que estamos a
falar em em produzir coisas em massa ter
unhas montagem com ajudou a cidade pois
é uma terceira fase que é fácil de
computação a comoção é e atualmente
estamos entrando na parte dos temas se
ver físicos e indústria 4 410 e obter
aqui já fala até numa quinta
basicamente em 2004 4.0 consciência em
um só temos computadores temos todo
automatizado tudo muito rápido mas temos
sistemas que são físicos sistemas também
estão na canton no qual temos muitos
dados e toda a comunicação interagir uns
com os outros
a tecnologia aqui o que pode fazer pode
trazer muitos muito especiais altamente
sensíveis pode ajudar reduz a problemas
continuarem com energia aie também pode
ajudar na computação da conta
quantidades muito grandes resultados
eventualmente não é eventualmente é é
muito grande aos negócios novos já volta
a volta do texto quando nós olharmos
aníbal aplicações
nós vemos que existem muitos tipos de
sensores muito tempo a todos os
munícipes tecnologias que são usados por
exemplo wells seja são sistemas com os
amigos sistemas em casa para tornar a
casa mais inteligente muito positivos
médicos aumento da automação industrial
toda a parte de
carros estão ligados e cada vez são mais
ligados à em que mais cedo ou mais tarde
vamos realmente é ter veículos ao
comportamento autônomos e também em
tópicos aqui já foram rolados de voz
sobre as cidades 200 martins a todos
este todas as suas aplicações nos aceita
pelos censores necessitam de microfones
e outros sensores que são os termômetros
no entanto os copinhos assessores
temperatura sensores fux a eventualmente
também precisa mesmo ser só os médicos
falavam tipo são ferramentas de
diagnóstico aumento integradas altamente
concentradas e que conseguem ser muito
sensíveis à parte não tecnologia micro e
nanotecnologia responsável pela maior
parte dos réus twill sócios pensarem no
dia a dia
são coisas que realmente usam atualmente
o telemóvel 15 pratos um carro tem
vários um carro também estarão
incorporados mesmo permitem por exemplo
fazer com que tenhamos uma condução mais
segura com 111 atualmente um astrólogo
conselho consegue disputar com um a
abertura de um rbr se a solução for uma
série negativa que afinal colisão
já sabemos que pode sequer pode ser
feito na hora como é que faço ea mulher
que eu vou dizer algumas coisas como
essas fazem também pois vou especificar
ainda mais aplicações petrôni estamos a
falar aqui é uma tecnologia que só são
feitas mas nem todos estejamos sensores
magnéticos basicamente a parte jurídica
ao microfone que eu não fui a única que
basicamente estamos a falar de chips
coisas são muito pequenas
eles permitem por exemplo fazer análise
o dodô muito pequenas quantidades sendo
muito sensíveis a quantidades muito
pequenas por exemplo células
cancerígenas que circulam no sangue
o treinador do real madrid no próximo
sensores por toda a parte de tecnologia
flexível com sal e na nos quais a virar
item cima algo que não vou ver
basicamente é 11 em uma matriz desde o
sensor importância que está sendo
implantada neste caso no cérebro do
ratinho
mas também existe atualmente existem
estes sensores que são que são são são
implantados e em duas partes anda para
lá em cima e que ao ser estimulada
certas partes do cérebro realmente
trazem como na vida ao paciente com
sensores - temos que mostrar a emoção
esse tema e que podem ser usados em
muitos hotéis por exemplo um denso é
parte do astronete novamente existe por
todo o lado
temos também toda toda uma tecnologia de
superfícies como é aqui que nos permitem
aumentar a área de uma área digamos
assim
ou seja eu posso ser um painel para
criar um dos pilares
eu vou ter não só o topo dos pilares
mais potente também toda a parte lateral
dos pilares ou seja aumentar a área
total é positivo se eu conseguir fazer
isso em seu início não vou ter paciência
muito maior
a qual vou vou tocar sempre tecnologias
micro e nano máquinas all stars um
truque mas nada nos quais 500 são os
engenheiros de parte a parte no nosso
fazer seu início e com isso nós fazemos
são membranas são os instrutores que
mexer no plano de plástico e os sensores
lá dentro dos termos técnicos sociais
permite por exemplo colar em vidro o
silêncio como eles são extremamente
forte
são basicamente são sensores em que tem
um sinal o sinal delson sinal de merda
uma consciência elétrica
muito muito muito fundamental evolução
do campo magnético aplicado quando nós
vamos olhar a pastora e estruturas são
bastante complicadas e que os efeitos
quânticos
mas se nós formos a ver mas não é ficção
científica nós temos nos automóveis
temos temos quase em somar os quase 100
sensores magnéticos e com essas
configurações por exemplo alguns
exemplos
o que acontece é que temos um sistema
permanente de 15 e um sensor magnético
consegue saber em que posição está a
implementação desse movimento promete
manter esse é o sistema atualmente para
para partirem único
o mesmo caso por exemplo só para a prova
exploração eletrônico mesma coisa usar
para monitorizar a posição dos vidros e
outros mais
e como isso também é usado em automóveis
também usado em fábricas para todo tipo
de monitorização grafeno é uma
tecnologia que também é muito incerto
não pelo não pelas propriedades
pecuárias do grafeno do ponto eletrônico
ou seja nós nunca nunca vamos ter
transistors mais rápidos
i com as dimensões nós temos por exemplo
conta que convenceu isso como como os 1
os avós que têm os telemóveis nos
computadores
o grafeno nunca vai permitir isso é uma
coisa vai prometer é nós temos sensors
altamente sensíveis o que acontece aqui
quando nós temos um transístor temos uma
uma determinada uma entrada para o
transistor que é chamada camada ativa
quando os anos referidos por aí para
essa camada ativa
nós estamos a falar de uma alternativa
que tem uma pessoa que só um ato em
qualquer coisa
durante a procissão do meu trânsito é
ruim em cima é a resposta elétrico vai
vai mudar e e e muito
portanto se eu conseguir funcionar usar
esse que é feito essa superfície do
grafeno eu consegui criar sensores por
exemplo é um dos que conseguem detetar
co2 conseguem detetar fome conseguem
detetar tenter conseguem dissertar a
substância no sangue
conforme instrumento essencial a pena
guardar funcionalização ia acabar mas
alguns exemplos já falar em nome de
antônio já falar em provas coisas que se
metem no cérebro coisas que sinto ao
então a parte tática também é muito
interessante ver aqui é um espaço em
qualquer esporte comércio
mexe numa direção e mostrou outra ou
seja se eu contar mais aqui o papel dos
pais e hora e posso fazer um movimento
com esse país possa fazer projeção não é
aí que eu viajo muito sistema de
projeção atualmente existentes
os dois tipos parte estive espanhóis
também são usados para para aplicações
em cuidar para que a condição é para
autônomos drive para condução autônoma
vocês pararam nesta escala está aqui nós
estamos a falar
um dispositivo completo que tem cerca de
três milímetros é que estamos a falar da
nossa cozinha porque os componentes
principais instrumentos são os que não
conseguem ver links são dentre
basicamente entrou lançados nos outros
que permitem ao praias positivos são da
ordem de saída 209 exemplo na computação
de grande quantidade de dados que é um
caso muito interessante saber que o fato
de algum número 005 fatorial fatorial e
543 milhões mesmo sobre service em
fatorial e 25 e 24 23 dram até ficaram
existem quase concurso computação não é
que temos aqui um supercomputador de
costas computadores que vem enquanto
chinesa que conseguem calcular um
treinado fatorial não é numericamente é
o que ela quer muito muito de computação
atualmente o que também já existe são
por exemplo sistemas de microcanais são
desenhados a tal maneira que quando se
introduzem por exemplo terry as outras
outros complementou
outras entidades biológicas aos
interagem e conseguem pôr os próprios
temos conseguem pôr os próprios am an
calcular nome fazer fazer computação
fazer cálculo também muito santo
não estamos a falar também de de
sistemas por exemplo substituir nenhum
um processador
então eu amava a um computador mas por
causa dos muitos cursinhos também
conseguem conversar e para acabar
quem são os utilizadores que quem
provocar quais são os pais que são os
núcleos pelo menos dois ou três produtos
quando na área de micro e nano
tecnologias
[Música]
alguns dos alunos dos pais por exemplo
falar mais nada em uma companhia que faz
o sistema de projeção com strauss parte
estamos a falar de desde sistemas feito
seu execução muito pequenos que
conseguem mt tanto som como o que fosse
maior
se vocês pensarem atualmente num
telemóvel um se um altifalante mesmo
quem é um sistema que é composto por 19
mil componentes
tenho certeza que todas montadas aqui
porto por tecnologia foi todo mesmo se
mostrado companhias por exemplo na área
do mall se encontrar algumas fábricas
como no turismo usando o mouse usam
todos os sensores
isso é realmente novos modelos de
negócios que que parecem por exemplo é
um exemplo que interpela o que os fazem
atualmente já não vendem já não vendem
as máquinas de construção simplesmente
alugam o pro o for necessário isso mas é
a única maneira de o poder fazer e tem
interesse temos completamente ligados à
nuvem completamente inutilizados todos
os quadrantes deus opção de pneus
estadual do motor exclusividade do motor
seu ato todo quer perceber como é que
tem que atuar ou não sobre o sistema
ian obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]